PRESIDENT BIDEN HITTING THE ROAD
PUSHING HIS MULTITRILLION DOLLAR
SPENDING PLAN AS HE BECOMES
INCREASINGLY UNPOPULAR.
>> THIS IS A TAX CUT, CHANGES
THE LIVES OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
SO LET'S GET THIS DONE, LET'S
MOVE.
WE HAVE THE MOST TALENTED
WORKFORCE IN THE WORLD, WHAT ARE
WE DOING?
WHAT IN GODS NAME ARE WE DOING?
BY THE WAY, YOU HEAR THESE
NUMBERS, 3.5 TRILLION OR
1.75 TRILLION, WE PAY FOR IT
ALL.
IT DOESN'T INCREASE THE DEFICIT
ONE SINGLE CENT.
>> Dana: WITH A BACKDROP OF
AMERICANS FACING PRODUCT
SHORTAGES, BIDENS APPROVAL KNOB
WOW NUMBERS LOSING MORE GROUND
FROM THE START OF HIS TERM THAN
ANY OTHER PRESIDENT.
AFFORDING THE HIGH PRICES ARE
HERE TO STAY.
>> WHEN DO YOU EXPECT THE
INFLATION TO GET BACK TO THE 2%
RANGE WHICH IS CONSIDERED
NORMAL?
2022, 2023, WHEN?
>> I EXPECT THAT TO HAPPEN NEXT
YEAR.
WE ARE GOING THROUGH A PERIOD OF
INFLATION THAT IS HIGHER THAN
AMERICANS HAVE SEEN IN A LONG
TIME, BUT WE HAVEN'T LOST
CONTROL.
>> Dana: SOME OF THE MEDIA
TELLING AMERICANS TO STOP
COMPLAINING.
WORRIED ABOUT THE SUPPLY CHAIN?
STOP BUYING SO MUCH STUFF WHICH
IS NOT THE MOST AMERICAN OF
ATTITUDES.
>> Jesse: NO, IT IS NOT.
AND WE GET THESE TYPES OF THINGS
WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE IN OFFICE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THE MEDIA CAN
SHIFT THE ACCOUNTABILITIES OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SO SHUT UP,
YOU PAMPERED SHOPAHOLIC AND
START LOWERING YOUR
EXPECTATIONS, THAT HAPPEN DURING
THE LAST DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT,
WE WOULD GET HIT WITH A DOMESTIC
TERROR ATTACK AND TOLD THAT'S
YOUR FAULT OR WE WOULD GET HIGH
GAS PRICES AND THEY'D SAY YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE BOUGHT THAT SUV
AND THEN A REPUBLICAN GETS IN
THE OFFICE AND EVERYTHING IS HIS
FAULT.
RACISM, SEXISM, YOUR GIRLFRIEND
HAS A DRINKING PROBLEM,
EVERYTHING ON THE EARTH IS THAT
PRESIDENTS PROBLEMS WITH THE
PROBLEM WITH JOE BIDEN AS HE IS
CREATING PROBLEMS AND THEN
IGNORING THE PROBLEMS HE'S
CREATING.
HE'S NOT DOING EITHER ONE AND
THAT'S WHY HIS POLL NUMBERS ARE
SLIDING SO DRAMATICALLY.
HE SEE HIS PICTURE, HE LOOKED
LIKE A TEN AND YOU MEET HIM AT
DINNER AND HE IS TWO.
>> Dana: HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE THINKING HOW
DO I GET OUT OF HERE?
HE HAD A BLURRY PICTURE DURING
THE ELECTION BECAUSE HE WAS
HIDING BY IT IN AND NOW HE IS IN
FULL FOCUS AND HE IS UGLY AND WE
DON'T LIKE THIS GUY SO NOW YOU
ARE SEEING JANET YELLEN COME OUT
THERE, CAN SHE GO ONE PATERNITY
LIKE MAYOR PETE DID?
EVERY TIME SHE OPENS HER MOUTH,
I'M SCARED.
SHE COMES OUT AND MRS. INFLATION
LAST YEAR AND NOW WE ARE HIT
WITH A MAJOR INFLATIONARY PERIOD
THAT'S GOING TO LAST UNTIL AT
LEAST NEXT YEAR AND THEN SHE
SAYS THIS, BUT WE HAVEN'T LOST
CONTROL.
IT IS IN THAT REASSURING FROM
THE TREASURY SECRETARY?
I FEEL SO MUCH BETTER THAT YOU
HAVEN'T LOST CONTROL BUT NOW YOU
HAVE HIGH PRICES AND LOW GROWTH
IN A WEAK DOLLAR AND THAT IS A
RECIPE FOR DISASTER.
>> Dana: COULD WE GET YOUR
TAKE ON ALL OF THAT?
>> Dagen: I THOUGHT IT WAS
WEIRD THAT SHE WAS STARING UP AT
THE CEILING LIKE THIS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE WAS
LOOKING AT BUT WHEN SOMEONE WILL
LOOK YOU IN THE EYE, THEY ARE
LYING TO YOU.
THIS IS AN UNPRECEDENTED
EXPERIMENT WITH THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THEY'VE BEEN PUMPING INTO
THE SYSTEM AND THEY HAVEN'T EVEN
BEGUN TO START PULLING BACK ON
IT, THAT ALONE IS GOING TO BE A
DISASTER.
BUT I DO LOVE IT IF YOU'RE
SPENDING IS GOING TO BE
SOCIALIST, THAN THE PAVED FOR IT
HAS TO BE SOCIALIST AND THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT THIS NEW ANNUAL
TAX ON CAPITAL GAINS WHICH IS A
WEALTH TAX.
I DON'T CARE WHAT ANYBODY SAYS,
YOU ARE CONFISCATING PEOPLE'S
WEALTH AND IT IS FRAUGHT WITH
PERIL, WEIGHS RAISES SO MANY
PROBLEMS WHETHER IT'S ONLY FOR
BILLIONAIRES, WHAT ENDS UP
HAPPENING IS THESE TAXES NEVER
RAISE ENOUGH MONEY, BILLIONAIRES
ARE GOING TO MOVE SO GOOD IS END
OF HITTING?
PEOPLE MUCH LOWER ON THE
FINANCIAL SCALE.
LOOK AT ALTERNATIVE MINIMUM TAX
DESIGNED TO HIT LESS THAN 200
PEOPLE HIT MILLIONS AND BILLIONS
OF PEOPLE BUT ALSO WILL EXPAND
THE POWER OF THE INTERNAL
REVENUE SERVICE AND IT'S
UN-AMERICAN AND UNCONSTITUTIONAL
BUT BIDEN'S GOVERNING FOR
APPLAUSE AND ACCOLADES OVERSEAS
WHICH IS WHERE HE IS GOING LATER
IN THE WEEK AND THAT'S WHY HE'S
GETTING THE DOUBLE MIDDLE FINGER
FROM AMERICANS WHO DRIVE AND
SHOP STORES.
>> Dana: BIGGEST DROP WAS WITH
DEMOCRATS AND INDEPENDENTS,
FREE FALL.
TO MAKE A LOT OF IT HAS TO DO
WITH THE FACT THAT HE KEEPS
YELLING AT US.
LIKE WERE POPPING WHEELIES ON
HIS FRONT YARD AND HE IS SHAKING
THE RAKE.
DO YOUR POINT ABOUT WE HAVEN'T
LOST CONTROL, THAT IS PART OF
THE WHOLE IDEA OF SETTING A LOW
BAR.
BUT THIS IS THE DEPENDS
PRESIDENCY.
THEY HAVE LOST CONTROL.
THE SLOGAN IS SUCK IT UP.
IT'S BEING PUSHED BY THE MEDIA
AS YOU SAW, THE SAME MEDIA THAT
ALLOWS ANY RESTRICTIONS OR
HOUSING, THAT WOULD BE SEEN AS
BIGOTED BUT IF YOU'RE AN
AMERICAN, YOU SUCK IT UP, YOU
HAVE TO DEAL WITH LOSS.
IN DIMINISHED AVAILABILITY OF
PRODUCTS SO PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
FROM AMERICA GET THE CARE IT BUT
AS THE CITIZENS WHO GET THE
STICK AND WHAT'S HILARIOUS IS
THEY ARE CITIZENS FOR BUYING
STUFF AFTER THEY GAVE THEM THE
MONEY TO BUY THE STUFF SO YOU'RE
TELLING US NOW WE MUST APPEAL TO
EVERY RATIONAL PUNITIVE
ANNOUNCEMENT, DON'T SPEND THAT
MONEY.
AND DON'T SAVE IT EITHER BECAUSE
THAT'S BAD.
YOU WANT AMERICANS TO PULL BACK,
YOU HAVE TO AS WELL.
NO MORE FLIGHTS TO PUSH CLIMATE
CHANGE, NO MORE MET GALA, NO
MORE DINING OUT AT INSANELY
PRICED, THIS LET THEM EAT CAKE
THING IS WEARING THE THING WHEN
WE CAN'T FIND ANY CAKE.
>> Dana: GOING TO NEW JERSEY
TO CAMPAIGN FOR THE DEMOCRAT
PHIL MURPHY, THEN PAYING A LOT
OF ATTENTION TO VIRGINIA, NOT
NEW JERSEY I'M A BIT EDUCATED
TODAY BY FRIENDS THAT THIS RACE
IS A LOT CLOSER, QUIETLY
TIGHTENED, DO YOU THINK THERE'S
A POSSIBILITY THE REPUBLICANS
COULD WIN IN NEW JERSEY?
>> PROBABLY NOT.
IT'S A BLUE STATE BUT WE TALKED
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT BEFORE
COMING ON, THIS WILL BE THE
FIRST TIME A DEMOCRAT IT'S FOR
GETS REELECTED.
SO THEN YOU ADD TO IT ALL OF THE
CONSTERNATION AROUND THE ISSUES
THAT WE RAISE HERE AND EVERY
OTHER DAY AROUND BIDEN IN THE
IMMIGRATION CRISIS AND HOW THIS
MIGHT BE BLEEDING OVER TO THESE
CANDIDATES BUT I WOULD REMIND
EVERYBODY AS MUCH AS WE SOUND
GLOOMY ABOUT THINGS, NOT THE
ONLY BAROMETER.
I'M A CAPITALIST, ALWAYS HAVE
BEEN AND THE DEMOCRATS I ALIGN
WITH WHAT ARE WE WHERE WE WANT
TO BE?
NO, NO DOUBT THAT PRICES HAVE
GOTTEN TOO HIGH BUT I'D REMIND
EVERYONE ALSO WE HAVE
INCENTIVIZED INVESTING IN THIS
COUNTRY AND TO FORCE MANAGEMENT
COMPANIES TO BE REALLY EFFICIENT
AND AS A RESULT, THAT EFFICIENCY
BREEDS A LOT OF THINGS INCLUDING
PROFITABILITY, MORE INVESTORS
BUT IF DEMAND GETS A LOPSIDED
ONE WAY, CREATES PROBLEMS.
THEY DIDN'T GET THIS RIGHT WITH
THE STIMULUS.
I'D MUCH RATHER EARN THIS AND
NOT GIVE THEM TOO MUCH BUT SET
IT AS WELL, SINCE 2007, WE'VE
HAD NOTHING BUT AN EXPERIMENT
WITH THE FEDERAL RESERVE AND
SOME OF IT THEY'VE GOTTEN RIGHT
IN SOME THEY'VE GOTTEN WRONG.
I WISH THEY HAD PULLED BACK AND
THAT'S WHAT I DON'T KNOW IF HE
WAS SAYING DON'T SPEND AS MUCH
ON STIMULUS ALTHOUGH HE DID SAY
A LITTLE OF THAT, HE WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FED'S WE'VE
GOT TO LOOK AT ALL OF THIS AND
WHEN THE FED DOES WHAT IT DOES
COME ON THE PEOPLE WHO WIN THE
MOST ARE RICH PEOPLE.
>> Dana: DO HAVE CONFIDENCE
THAT THEY'RE LISTENING TO THOSE
ISSUES?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE WAS
LOOKING AT WHEN SHE WAS TALKING
BUT SHE IS SMART AND SHE IS
CAPABLE AND CLEARLY, THEY HAVE
THE TOOLS TO DO WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE.
BUT POLITICALLY, I THINK THE
COUNTRY IS BLAMING DEMOCRATS FOR
THIS MONTH BY THE PRESIDENT WAS
IN NEW JERSEY AND WHY HE WILL
HAVE TO GO TO VIRGINIA.
THERE IS ONE G